la revue de presse avec vos hélène frade
bien sûr bonjour hélène bonjour pauline
dans la presse internationale l'émotion
toujours très vives et les témoignages
absolument terrible après la découverte
de fosses communes dans des villages
d'ukrainiens d'où l'armée russe s'est
retiré une femme à genoux qui pleure son
mari tué dans la banlieue de kiev il y
aura un avant et un après vous de chats
annonce la croix qui évoque ce matin de
possibles crimes de guerre et crimes
contre l'humanité
butch haïr pin mais aussi au sto mail au
nord de la capitale ont été les
épicentres des exactions de l'armée
russe selon le figaro de l'envoyé
spécial a interrogé une psychologue qui
a reçu des femmes et des jeunes filles
affirmant avoir été violées par des
militaires russes dans les territoires
qu'ils ont occupé des histoires qui se
ressemblent comme si les russes avaient
planifié tout cela d'après caterina
alliant tu d'abord le matin ou l'après
midi les soldats vérifiait qui vivaient
dans les maisons puis il revenait le
soir tu es les hommes du foyer pillé
l'argent et les objets précieux
mangeaient et buvaient ce qu'ils
trouvaient dans la maison et quand il
était saoul violer les filles et les
femmes racontent elles face à ces
témoignages terrifiant les appels à
renforcer les sanctions contre moscou se
multiplient note financial times cite l
appel des états unis et de la france en
faveur d'une escalade significative des
sanctions contre la russie emmanuel
macron demandant l'interdiction des
importations de pétrole et de charbon
russe mais pas du gaz russe qui reste
crucial on le sait pour l'italie les
pays d'europe de l'est et l'allemagne
outre-rhin le gaz russe continue de
couler mais der spiegel fait état d'une
pression d'une résistance grandissante
contre les importations russes
l'allemagne et d'autres pays lieu
veulent t'ils continue à transférer des
centaines de millions d'euros par jour
va la russie alors que le pays poursuit
sa guerre d'anéantissement de l'ukraine
interpelle le magasin la russie hélène
dont beaucoup de voix africaines
défendent en revanche l'invasion de
l'ukraine mediapart explique cette
position par les liens historiques de
certains de ces pays avec la russie se
nouent et plus récemment autour de
partenariat militaire comme au mali ans
centre centrafrique ou encore des formes
de dépendance économique
le site d'info français évoque aussi
l'expression d'une détestation de
l'occident la poutine au filet d'une
partie des africains relèvent mois d'une
adhésion à la politique russe que du
rejet ce sur fond d' anticiper ria
l'isthme de l'europe et de l'occident
selon le chercheur camerounais paul
simon andy mediapart site également
l'analyse de l'universitaire rémi adecco
ya sur le fait que plusieurs dirigeants
du continent africain a espère peut-être
aussi voir la russie leur sauver la mise
c'est leur pouvoir venaient à être
menacés comme ce fut le cas on le sait
en syrie avec le président bachar al
assad sur le continent ont toujours
l'armée malienne indiqué avoir éliminé à
la fin du mois dernier plus de 200
jihadistes amoura où des exactions
auraient aussi été commises selon
plusieurs sources locales le courrier
international relais les interrogations
de la presse africaine sur ce qui s'est
réellement passé dans ce petit village
du centre du mali on a envie d'applaudir
à tout rompre cette grandissime
illustration de la montée en puissance
des forces armées maliennes hélas
amnesty international la mission des
nations unies pour le mali et des
témoins expriment leur préoccupation si
ce n'est leur indignation après que les
militaires et leurs alliés russes ont
tiré dans le tas le jour de la foire du
village commente le journal burkinabè
l'observateur paalga qui estime pauline
que les russes du groupe paramilitaire
wagner venus prêter main forte à l'armée
malienne sont loin d'être blanc comme
neige un mot à présent de la décision du
propriétaire de liberté algérie l'un des
derniers grands titres de la presse
indépendante algérienne dont vous parlez
souvent hélène sur ce plateau décision
de fermer le journal jeune afrique
évoqué un coup de tonnerre dans le
paysage dia tic algeria après l annonce
faite par le propriétaire du journal le
milliardaire issad rebrab de la tenue
demain d'une assemblée générale dont
l'ordre du jour sera le dépôt de bilan
et la dissolution pure et simple du
titre une disparition annoncée que le
magazine attribué en réalité des motifs
politiques le journal ayant essuyé à
plusieurs reprises ces derniers mois de
vives critiques de la part des autorités
y compris du président algérien lui même
abdelmadjid they would qui accusait
liberté algérie de jeter de l'huile sur
le feu je le cite après un dossier
consacré à la pénurie de denrées zoli de
denrées alimentaires cette décision de
sabordage provoque la stupeur et
l'incompréhension au sein de la
rédaction de liberté algérie mais aussi
au delà comme en témoigne cette tribune
signée par plusieurs intellectuels
universitaires chercheurs et artistes
algériens qui se disent profondément
attachés au pluralisme médiatique et
refuse je les cite de rester insensible
face à la disparition d'un titre qui
porte la voix plurielles de l'algérie on
en reparlera bien sûr on ne sait petit
pas là dessus on attendait vendredi
ramin je vous propose de jeter un cil au
rapport du giec le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat pour parvenir à limiter le
réchauffement à un degré et demi d'ici
2025 alors les experts préviennent que
des changements majeurs sont nécessaires
mais qu'il faut aussi faire évoluer les
modes de vie le métro man ici étant la
sobriété alors concrètement qu'est ce
que ça veut dire par exemple privilégier
la marche le vélo à la voiture réduire
les déplacements en avion limiter le
recours aux appareils électriques ou
encore adopter un régime alimentaire
- carnets c'est à dire pour votre petit
déjeuner ce matin un petit jus d'orange
pressé à l'ama et une petite tartine
beurrée 1 plutôt qu'une tranche de bacon
gagner c'est bon pour la planète et puis
c'est bon pour la ligne aussi bien sûr
eu une baguette et c'est tout merci
beaucoup elana